fate
took me to villa yet some years back an
account of my
strange experiences on sea and land
ought to be
entertaining and educative if i weren't
sadly
lacking in literary ability
in this year of the hedgerow 1199 as the
unrest and
anarchy all around me makes me anxious
distressed and
so often upset as to deprive me of
reason
it is only at the insistence of friends
that i take
up pen and paper to inscribe my
impressions
of the visit all i can leave as a mark
on the pages of time
by which i may be remembered is this
account of a few
curious incidents
[Music]
it was january 1766 my preparations
complete
i put my trust in allah's mercy and got
ready to board monsieur corville's ship
at hichly harbour as the ship weighed
anchor and
spread sail only allah could have known
the intensity of my grief
but leaving my native land and kinsmen
the earth is like a floating egg amidst
the sea's immensity
i have heard that in an attempt to plumb
the sea's depth
a fearing gee king had a rope dropped
into it
at the distance of a day's journey from
the shore
millions of yards disappeared and yet
the rope didn't touch
bottom indians who have no first-hand
knowledge of the sea
believe that alexander the great plumbed
and surveyed
all the world's seas it is an
utterly erroneous belief in no
circumstances can it be true
the sea is bottomless
[Music]
our ship anchored a couple of miles from
the shore
at the french port of nantes
one of our guns fired a signal in
response to which a pilot boat was sent
to guide us to the wharf of the french
east india company
the whole operation took about two hours
as soon as we docked
vendors flocked to the ship bearing
fruits bread
cheese biscuits and butter the sailors
who had not seen such fresh fare for six
months
regaled themselves on it and were
generally overjoyed at seeing their
homeland again
i could well understand their feelings
one thing astonished me the lower orders
among the french are so
poor that they cannot afford shoes and
as a substitute wear wooden sandals
there are poor people in england too but
they do not suffer for want of leather
boots and socks
captain swinton and mr peacock laughed
at the sight of the miserable frenchman
in their comical footwear
and said these people are so wretched
because they are not industrious
like the english
[Music]
captain swinton and mr peacock went to
look for lodgings in the town
i had to remain on board for two or
three days more
during which time i learned a little
about the people of the region
and their laws and customs
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming
service so mining coco's recommendation
this week
is ancient inventions a fascinating
study
of the origins of some of the things
that we take for granted
kisses flamethrowers brain surgery
day-to-day stuff
coco's been inspired to actually invent
something herself
a special ambush tower to attack other
cats
absolutely ruthless magellan has been a
great supporter of content
from me and my brother at history time
for a while now
it's a sort of netflix for documentaries
with a huge range of great history stuff
among loads of other genres including a
documentary
about cats click on the link in the
description for an exclusive
month-long free trial for voices of the
past viewers
[Music]
[Music]
thanks
the houses in the country are built of
stone slabs
with roofs of terracotta tiles as the
bamboo doesn't grow here the scaffolding
of the roofs is built of wood
the poorer classes live on a diet of
broth and
barley bread and wear coarse wool or
clothes woven from
hemp of which ropes are also spun paris
the capital of france is several hundred
miles from either calais
or nante frenchmen and foreigners sing
alike high praises of the buildings and
gardens of that city its
artistic innovations scientific and
technological advancement
the polished manners cultivation
well-spokenness and wit of its
inhabitants
in these respects it far surpasses all
other cities
in the firingy world the french
claim that they have taught music and
horsemanship to the english
wealthy englishmen send their children
to french schools to polish up their
manners and taste the french say that
the present excellence of the english in
the arts and sciences trade and industry
is the result of french education in the
past when they lacked this education
they were ignorant like the mass of
indians
however even the french admit that the
english have always been
outstanding soldiers i
realized quickly that the french are a
conceited race
whose conversation was always an attempt
to display their own superiority
and to unfairly belittle other nations
can i say in praise of london there is
no
city on earth as large or beautiful and
it is beyond my powers to describe it
fittingly
like calcutta it straddles a river that
falls into the sea
the distance from london to the sea is
roughly the distance between calcutta
and huli about three days journey sea
going ships sail up river
and anchor at the city gat in front of
the east india company headquarters
about four miles from the royal palace
the city is a london's commercial
district
where merchants and tradesmen have their
businesses
not far from the city is the ancient
fort known as the
tower it is built of blackstone and is
very strong
in london there are countless buildings
of brick but few of stone
however i observed that churches both
old and new
are mostly built of stone among them the
most
imposing is saint paul's cathedral its
splendid design and excellent
construction defy description
and must be seen to be appreciated up to
half its height is cruciform in design
while the upper half is a giant cupola
of
stained glass such as is used to roof
harman's
[Music]
at the base of the cupola is a circular
gallery which is reached by an outside
staircase
on our climbing up to it captain swinton
walked round to the eastern side
then he asked me in a whisper munchie
what are you doing
though we were 40 cubits apart i heard
him clearly
i replied in the same tone i am looking
at the sights
he too heard me distinctly this is
possible because the air confined within
the dome
acts as an excellent medium for the
transmission
of sound
one day some people took me to a dance
party at the house of one of their
friends
as soon as i entered the music and
dancing stopped the assembled ladies and
gentlemen
thronged round me in wide-eyed amazement
and examined my robe turban shawl and
the other parts of my costume
they concluded that it was the costume
of a dancer
or actor and invited me to join the
dance
i protested that i had no knowledge of
the art of dancing
but they refused to believe me they said
that there was nobody on earth who
didn't know something
of music and dancing one of the english
gentlemen said that as i was
newly arrived in england i was perhaps
feeling shy to dance with
ladies of another race at this the
ladies
tittered with amusement they continued
to stare at my clothes and countenance
while i gazed at their astonishing
loveliness
just as i had been depressed by the
hardships of the voyage
i now felt elated by the beautiful
sights
of london it is a sign of the generosity
of the english
which i cannot find words to describe or
praise
a traveler from abroad is dearer to them
than their own life
and they will take great pains to make
them happy
within a couple of months everyone in
the neighborhood became
friendly the fear which some had felt
vanished completely
and they would now jest at me the ladies
of the bazaar
approached me and smiling said
come my dear and kiss me
[Music]
the cold winter in europe doesn't allow
one to grow indian fruits and flowers in
the open
a special kind of house is constructed
for the purpose
three sides of which are brick while the
fourth which faces south
is made of glass plates that keep out
the cold air
but let in the sun's rays in the cold
season
stoves are lit in the house for heat and
fruit and flower seeds are sown in
troughs
filled with mold the heat of the stoves
and the warmth of the sunlight
combine to aid the growth of indian
plants
european gardeners grow eastern fruits
in this manner and make a very good
profit
charging as much as five rupees for a
pomegranate
and three for a musk melon
brick buildings in bengal have rooms
with high
ceilings and large doors and windows so
that there is a soothing current of air
in hot weather
it is exactly the opposite in europe
there is extreme cold frost and snow the
ceilings are low and the doors and
windows small
the roofs are not flat like the roofs of
brick buildings in india
wooden beams and planks are used to
build the frame of the roof
in the shape of a camel's hump that is
to say
like the slanting thatched roofs of huts
in bengal
in vilayet the arrangements for
performances of music and dance
are very different from that in india in
our country the
idol rich higher professional singers
and dancers for
private performances in their homes
where they invite their cronies
this practice is quite alien to villaiet
where a group of impresarios jointly
form a company
and build a huge performing hall
or theater in which they put on public
shows they hire highly paid singers and
dancers of both sexes
and musicians who have been trained to
perfection by rare maestros
to put on their song and dance
decked in expensive costumes and jewelry
before an audience that includes both
rich
and poor londoners and even the emirs of
the land
the princes of the realm sometimes the
king himself
the entry fee varies with the quality of
the seat
in villaret when a spectator pays the
entry fee he is given a slip of paper on
which the class of his seat is mentioned
charming music from violins and guitars
many
strange dramatic pieces curtains of many
colours
antics of habshi performers dancers
lovely as horus
all these make a highly entertaining
spectacle
talking is not allowed in the theater
though the audience is large there is no
noise or clamor
when they are pleased by a performance
instead of shouting shabash
or wah wah as we do in india they stamp
on the floor or
clap their hands
i learned that there is a coastal region
in france whose inhabitants differ
slightly from other frenchmen
in customs and manners an ambitious and
powerful king of this region
attacked england with a huge army
conquered the tiny english kingdoms
and united them with ireland in one
large empire
this king through his justice and
even-handedness
won the hearts of english commoners and
noblemen alike
he began to mingle with his english
subjects and adopted their customs and
manner
the english counted themselves lucky to
have such a just and powerful king
captain swinton and i left oxford for
scotland in winter
this was when i saw snow for the first
time
it is like a beer the powder hindus
sprinkle on each other at the holy
festival
only instead of being coloured it is a
brilliant white
it falls from the sky like dust blown by
the wind
and covers the ground hills houses trees
bushes rivers and lakes
like molten wax
when the cold becomes very intense the
water in rivers lakes and canals
freezes into hard ice which is smooth
and white as marble
or like a sheet of crystal or glass
the water may freeze to a depth of five
or ten cubits
in which case pedestrians horsemen
carriages
loaded wagons and even elephants can
easily cross it
sometimes snowfall is so heavy that
streets and alleys are covered
knee-deep overnight thus in the morning
householders have to
set their servants to work with spades
and shovels to clear a path in front of
their doors
when excessive snowfall covers roads
ditches and fields like a
sheet of white glass and there is no
sign of the road
carriages horses and loaded wagons can
easily slip into deep pits
causing deaths such an accident occurred
near oxford that year
when a loaded dre with 13 men and four
horses
fell into a pit
on our journey i observed people
traveling on the ice in an amazing
manner
[Music]
i was told that they could cover as much
as 20 miles an hour
i had heard stories of this means of
travel from sahib's in india
but it seemed so extraordinary that i
couldn't believe them now that i saw it
myself
my doubts vanished the manner in which
these people travel on ice
is as follows wooden souls like the
wooden slippers kadam of india are taken
to the middle of the wood is attached a
piece of polished steel
one span in length and half a fingers
breadth the hole is attached
tightly to the foot with leather straps
when the person stands up
the piece of steel is straight upon the
ice if the foot slips or is bent to one
side
the person will fall down it takes some
practice even to stand up in these shoes
as they glide along in their white robes
the europeans appeared like
angels who had descended on earth and
were moving about
[Music]
after a short time we arrived in
scotland which is directly to the north
of england
the country is divided into lowlands and
highlands the
latter being the high north mountains
and forests abound in scotland
consequently the population is
relatively sparse and towns and cities
fewer than in england
the scots are an abstemious hardworking
and brave people
who consider themselves superior to the
english who they say are
gluttonous and cowardly the english on
the other hand
account themselves superior in wealth
and education and despise the scotch as
being
poor and stupid though english is the
language of both countries
it differs from one to the other in a
few terms
the highlanders wear a jacket and cap
but neither breeches
nor boots the lower part of the body is
covered by a
skirt called a kilt but the knee is bare
and cotton stockings are worn on the
legs
in edinburgh we put up at the house of
captain swinton's father
captain swinton introduced me to his
parents both of whom were about
80 years old they had five children
three sons the eldest of which was
called john and two grown-up daughters
both spinsters
in villa yet a marriage is contracted
through the mutual consent
of man and woman ideally the man should
be
good-looking of an agreeable temper with
an income whether inherited or earned in
business or employment
the woman likewise should be attractive
of a good disposition
well-versed and at least some of the
fine arts and with a portion either from
her father
or former husband it is relatively rare
and a truly fortunate match
where all these good qualities are
present some people
however look only for wealth
if a woman is both ugly and poor
none will have her for villate is the
emporium of beauty
where women of surpassing loveliness are
common
and wealthy and virtuous ones are not
hard to find
consequently there are thousands of old
women who have never seen the face of a
[Music]
husband
the noteworthy powers in europe are the
holy roman empire
italy germany prussia russia denmark
portugal holland spain france england
turkey and three other countries whose
names i do not recall at the moment
these are all monarchies with the
exception of tiny holland
the land of the dutch people which is
governed by its noblemen
the rest of its inhabitants are affluent
merchants but as the waters off their
coast abound in fish
there are also many fishermen and fish
sellers as a result of which
other europeans contemptuously refer to
the dutch
as fishmongers the roman
empire is very old at one time
all the other firingy lands owed it
allegiance
the languages of italy and france are
sweet and elegant
and they are studied by the english on
this account and also because there are
many classics of science and philosophy
written in them without acquaintance
with which one is not considered
learned italy france and germany are
powerful states
but spain is richest of all the feringy
nations
this is because most of the gold mines
in the new world
have fallen in spanish colonies the
spaniards have a reputation for being
clever
and hard-working they may in fact be
more so than even the english i was told
that france italy and germany put
together
equal india in area but russia is at
least
three times india's size
historians tell us that just as the
english are now more famous than all
other nations
the portuguese were once prominent among
the christian kingdoms
for their wealth and military might
their ships were the first to reach
bengal
and other parts of south asia tiring
ghees began
thinking of searching out a sea route to
the east so that their ships could trade
directly with these regions
finally the portuguese king a bold and
ambitious man
came forward eventually his fleet
reached a cape
midway between europe and india it is a
corner of the land of the
habshis or black people and at the
southern end of the world
the sailors reasoned that there couldn't
be much of the earth left further to the
south
and so by circumventing the cape they
should be able to reach
south asia for inspiring such optimism
this point was named the cape
of good hope when news of this discovery
reached europe
the firing geese threw their hats into
the air for joy
after nine years of struggle portuguese
ships reached
india the fearing geese were overjoyed
at the success of the expedition
as if they had conquered the whole world
before long all the hat-wearing nations
of europe french
english dutch and danish came one after
another
and set up trading centers
i am no specialist in the history
beliefs and rituals of the
christians but i learned something about
these matters from english books and
translations of the
evangels which i will summarize at the
root
of christianity is the belief that
hazrat issa
is the son of god which christians claim
is borne out by the fact
the virgin mary bore him without having
known man most christian nations adore
jesus christ and bibi maryam like
allah they place effigies of christ and
mary in their churches and worship them
but the english consider such idolatry
improper and keep their churches devoid
of such images
they believe allah is without form
[Music]
there is much bigotry among the
christian nations
if a muslim were to go there and give
the azan and openly practice the right
of islam
he would be instantly burnt at the stake
but the english are free of such bigotry
even if one were to build a mosque in
england and pray and fast as
allah enjoins no objection would be
raised
for the english say what is it to us
what the religion of another may be
captain swinton tried everything he
could to induce me to stay on for
another three or four years
but i could not but decline being so
depressed at my separation from my
native land and friends
that i cared little about acquiring
riches or temporal advantages
i returned to bengal in 1769.
i had spent a whole year aboard ship for
the round trip
one year in england and scotland seven
months in madras
and two months at different ports of
call which comes to two years
and nine months for the entire trip for
being permitted
to return safely to my native country i
give praise
and thanks to the almighty
you